in the sequence above the first term is
1 and each term after the first is twice
the preceding term what is the sum of
the sixteenth seventeenth and eighteenth
terms in the sequence so let's ride the
sequence down again so it's one two four
eight sixteen and just keeps going on
and on and on so the first term here
this is the first term what is this well
one way to think about it is that this
is two to the zero power and then our
second term right over here this is two
to the first power and then our third
term right over here this is two to the
second power our fourth term here you
see the pattern this is two to the third
power our fifth term in the sequence
this is two to the fourth power so if we
were to go to the sixteenth seventeenth
and eighteenth terms so let's go there
so if we were to go to if we were to go
to the so dot dot if we were to go to
the sixteenth seventeenth and eighteenth
term the 16th term is going to be if we
just follow this pattern right over here
it's going to be 2 to the 1 minus less
than the term power right when it's the
fifth term it's the 4th power and it's
the fourth term is the third power so
it's going to be 2 to the 15th power
this is going to be 2 to the 16th power
and this is going to be 2 to the 17th
power and so what's the sum of the
sixteenth seventeenth and eighteenth
terms in the sequence well it's going to
be it's going to be 2 to the 15th plus 2
to the 16th plus 2 to the 17th now this
is accurate but if you were taking this
on a test and this wasn't of the form
that they have it in we could try to
manipulate this a little bit and the one
way to manipulate it would be well see
let's try to factor out a 2 to the 15th
power so if you factor out a 2 to the
15th power so this is going to be 2 to
the 15th times so 2 to the 15th divided
by 2 to the 15th it's just going to be
12 to the 16th divided by 2 to the 15th
well just ask or going to be too all
right let me write that down to to the
16th over 2 to the 15th that's
equivalent to two to the 16 minus 15th
power
which is just equal to 2 to the first
which is just equal to 2 so that's going
to be 1 plus 2 and then finally to to
the 17th to to the 17th divided by 2 to
the 15th is equal to 2 to the second
power or just for so just for right over
there and they're so and this obviously
will simplify to 1 plus 2 plus 4 is just
7 it's just seven so the answer to their
question it would be 7 times 2 to the
15th so it'd be 7 times 2 to the 15th
power